[Musique]
bonjour jean luc lennon bonjour monsieur
le ton membres du chum du vent doux vent
et président de l'association sauvez la
santé en martinique on va faire court on
va faire très simple ce matin jean-luc
fait non on est en train de construire
tout simplement vaste désert médical à
l'échelle de la martinique
si rien ne bouge pour constater que rien
ne bouge
effectivement notre difficulté dans
notre territoire c'est l'attractivité
pour les médecins qui seraient
susceptibles de s'intéresser s'installer
en martinique temps temps à l'hôpital
que dans le libéral nous constatons qu
on a moins de médecins généralistes
moins de médecins spécialistes
parfois dans des proportions extrêmement
importante et l'hôpital vit aujourd'hui
de grandes difficultés dans de très
nombreuses spécialités la
gastroentérologie la la néphrologie la
neurologie la gériatrie toutes ces
spécialités sont en grande difficulté
parce que nous avons nous n'arrivons pas
à recruter des médecins
d'autant plus qu'on va devoir composer
avec une donne quand même
eh bien c'est la reconstruction du chu
de pointe à pitre qui devraient être
opérationnels au milieu des années 2020
après les 110 qui la ravage en novembre
2010 cette pointe à pitre risque de
faire concurrence à fort de france
oui en 2024 pointe à pitre à un bâtiment
tout neuf sur un seul site
versus notre situation en martinique où
nous sommes étalés sur six sites
distants de plusieurs dizaines de
kilomètres ce qui génère des coûts
importants
il n'existe aucun exemple d'un hôpital
qui soit finir c'est financièrement
équilibré aujourd'hui en france et qui
soit multi sites
alors pour la vider à la dégradation des
infrastructures des services importants
qui sont négligés qui peinent à trouver
du personnel des services qui ferment et
il faut trouver dans ce contexte des
médecins qu'ils fassent souche je
reprends votre expression des médecins
qui viendra martinique déjà dans un 1er
mai 30 et qui envisageraient de
s'installer c'est de là que le problème
est le plus épineux
oui parce que
certes on peut toujours invoquer le
souhait de recruter en martinique des
médecins d'origine martiniquaise qui
aurait donc été qui aurait tant que
qu'ils soient nés en martinique et qui
est vécu et qui une fois leurs études
terminées reviennent il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas une
faculté de médecine de plein exercice
c'est à dire qu'après la troisième année
les étudiants partent sur le territoire
hexagonal y reste jusqu'en sixième année
passe à ce moment là
jusqu'à maintenant en examen classant
national qui en fonction de l'heure de
leur place leur permettent d'envisager
telle ou telle spécialité
ils peuvent choisir ils choisissent
également une région donc ils peuvent
choisir de venir un travailleur martic
mais ils peuvent également faire le
choix d'aller en occitanie dans le nord
parce que ou à paris
c'est lorsqu'on leur fait de longues
études ailleurs on peut rencontrer par
exemple son futur conjoint d'avoir envie
de rester dans une zone géographique
précise ça c'est très embêtant c'est
très embêtant parce que c'est
effectivement à cet âge là c'est à cet
âge là que se forment les couples et si
votre futur conjoint est breton ou
toulousain eq il
ça c'est là une des premières raisons
mais la deuxième c'est que à choisir
entre un hôpital qui bénéficie de toutes
les structures les appareils de dernière
génération des conditions de travail
idéales à choisir entre un hôpital où
les dont on connaît aujourd'hui l'état
de délabrement et d'abandon sur le plan
architectural
eh bien on va on va rester à toulouse
alors c'est quand même penser à la main
d'oeuvre étrangère et agnès buzet la
ministre de la santé semblait aller dans
votre sens en affirmant qu'elle
défendrait cette proposition sauf que la
ministre a fait crabes elle a fait
marche arrière toute
on sait que c'est possible pour la
guyane c'est possible pour l'âme pour
mayotte et pour nous non alors pourquoi
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya eu un
revirement de position de la position de
la ministre
quand elle est venue en septembre 2018
ici en martinique et nous l'avons
rencontrée et cette proposition de
d'avoir une dérogation ne permettant de
recruter des médecins d'origine hors
union européenne
elle savait qu ebay par exemple par
exemple aux cubains mais ça peut être
aussi d'autres d'autres nationalités
elle s'était engagée à soutenir cette
position et il nous avait assuré de son
concours faites sur des contrats à durée
déterminée même si c'est au cas par cas
pas une enveloppe globale
voilà c'est ce qu'expliquait lesquels et
dit non je pense que il y a
il y à des lobbys qui s'opposent le
conseil de l'ordre national par exemple
alors que le conseil
oui c'est le plus grand des paradoxes
c'est que on nous a toujours opposé que
il ya déjà eu une expérience similaire
en guyane il y a quelques années qui
s'était soldée par un échec
on dit même une catastrophe et on n'a
pas bien compris que cette catastrophe
supposée en guyane est permis de
relancer cette expérimentation alors que
nous demandions nous la possibilité
extrêmement limité très restreinte sous
contrôle aux mutations choisi en tout
cas oui parce que nous avons des
collègues d'origine étrangère qui
parlent français qui ont fait souvent
leurs études en france qui ont une haute
spécialité dans dans leur domaine et que
l'on connaît personnellement et ce sont
ces médecins a spécialement que nous
avions pointé et qui est que risky
aurait été susceptible de d'améliorer
les situations particulières sauf que
bâle abusé a dit non alors vous avait
alerté les parlementaires de martinique
qu'est-ce qu'il vous dise et puis
surtout on pourrait s'interroger sur le
rôle de l'agencé régionale de santé qui
est ici qu elle son agent et son antenne
ici elle voit bien la situation et elle
fait remonter quoi cette agence
régionale de santé au ministère alors
l'agencé régionale de santé
juste avant les débats parlementaires
juste avant la loi
le vote de la loi santé était
extrêmement confiante et nous avait
assuré que le problème était réglé que
oui nous aurions cette possibilité de
recruter des médecins à diplôme étranger
je crois qu'ils l'ont été que l'agent ça
a été aussi surprise que nous du
revirement de du ministre les
parlementaires font leur métier
ce sont des parlementaires ils ont
répandu très rapidement on a été
extrêmement satisfait de la réaction
puisque
on les a alertés et invités à une
réunion en 48 heures ils sont tous venus
ont tous été représentés et ils nous ont
rassurés la de la loi santé c'est ça la
navette parlementaire et la question
reviendra au niveau au niveau du sénat
au moins on est jamais mais alors la
situation jean luc soit non la situation
en ce moment c'est que faute de bêtes
c'est faute de spécialistes faute de
service pas toujours et efficace mais
notre population tout cas celle qui a
les moyens par se faire soigner en
france mais il ya des urgences parfois
parfois on ne peut pas voyager tout
simplement parce que prendre l'avion
avec tel type de pathologie c'est pas
possible donc nous sommes dans un
système à plusieurs vitesses dans le
système français
il faut alerter alerter la population
pour lui expliquer que nous n'avons
qu'un hôpital en martinique qui
représente 90 % des hospitalisations
c'est pas du tout la même situation en
guadeloupe par exemple que en cas
d'urgence si vous devez être soigné
c'est inévitablement à l'hôpital au chu
que vous vous aboutirez parce que c'est
le seul système de santé qui vous
permettent d'être soigné 24 heures sur
24 avec la possibilité de requérir
n'importe quelle spécialité
si cet hôpital dysfonctionne si nous ne
pouvons pas assurer la qualité des soins
à l'égal de ce que nous pouvons réclamer
partout sur le territoire et bien dans
une situation imaginez une situation
exceptionnelle que personne ne souhaite
un séisme un cyclone de grande amplitude
des zones multirisques on le rappelle
épidémie tsunamis éruptions volcaniques
et ses cyclones au cumulant les
handicaps et nous avons donc d'autant
plus besoin d'avoir incité un hôpital
opérationnel sur lequel tous les acteurs
de santé se reposent les cliniques les
médecins libéraux ont absolument besoin
de cet outil que représente hôpital on a
dit vous êtes membre du chum doux vent
doux vent on a senti un moment que le
personnel du chu se mobilisaient
pas mal l'impression que c'est un peu
plus discret c'est par lassitude c'est
parce qu'ils auront ils ont été déçus de
tant de sacrifices de tant de luttes qui
n'ont pas donné grand chose finalement
oui je pense qu'aujourd'hui et les les
les équipes sont clairement des motivés
elles ont le sentiment que malgré toutes
leurs
tous les mouvements tous les espoirs que
l'on avait mis sur un certain nombre de
de lutte avec des résultats puisque qui
ont été sanctionnés puisque l'hôpital a
été mise sous administration provisoire
nous avons changé directeur nous avons
changé directeurs des ars
mais on a l'impression que ses fusibles
n'ont pas changé le fond de la situation
notre hôpital et un hôpital qui est en
faillite cette faillite et structures
sur millions par an 100 millions par an
et ça ne va pas ça ne va pas s'arranger
et les seuls les seuls médicaments qui
ont été proposées consistent à fermer
des services a diminué les personnels et
à le pape et les charges sociales
bobards hauteur de bord et à ne pas
payer les charges sociales ce qui a
permis de diminuer la dimension et le
temps de paiement des fournisseurs qui
explique qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
de gants dans les services merci au
revoir quand même rappeler le budget du
chu de fort de france et entre 500 et
600 millions remercie jean luc chagnon
d'avoir été avec nous rappelle que vous
êtes le président de l'association
sauvez il a senti en martinique bonne
journée merci merci pour ton
[Musique]